Grazie a tutti
Va bene, va bene
Grazie
Buonasera
Avete notato fino a mezzanotte il firmacopio, è vero?
Allora, noi siamo qui stasera per parlare del delitto Matteotti
non tanto di Matteotti, lui
ma proprio del delitto e del processo
dei colpevoli, dei mandanti
perché non è solo perché
è l'anno dell'anniversario ovviamente
sono cent'anni dal 1924
e se ne è parlato tanto in tutta Italia
non è solo perché siamo in piazza Matteotti
viva Dio
ma è davvero perché
col tema del festival di quest'anno
questa faccenda c'entra particolarmente bene
il tema del festival di quest'anno è la gratitudine
e per raccontare la gratitudine
bisogna avere ben chiaro che cos'è
e quindi anche che cos'è il suo contrario
l'ingratitudine
e la storia dei colpevoli del delitto Matteotti
e di come è andato il loro processo
e dei loro rapporti con Mussolini
è una storia
vedrete voi stessi
giudicherete voi stessi
ma mi direte
è una storia in cui
il tema dell'ingratitudine
c'entra in pieno
l'ingratitudine di Mussolini
per questi uomini suoi
uomini suoi di fiducia
che erano convinti di averlo servito bene
togliendo di mezzo Matteotti
ma anche l'ingratitudine di questi uomini
che il fascismo aveva portato
al potere, alla ricchezza
e che poi
non appena si trovano nei guai
rinnegano, si scannano fra loro
ricattano, minacciano
una storia straordinaria vedrete
in cui appunto l'unica cosa che dispiace
è che sparisce un po' lui, Matteotti
che sarebbe un personaggio che meriterebbe
come dire, un'altra lezione
per raccontare lui
ma qui invece noi raccontiamo
quelli che l'hanno ammazzato
ed è una storia straordinariamente rivelatrice
di che cos'era
quell'Italia
nei primissimi
o meglio, non quell'Italia
il gruppo dirigente
chi comandava in Italia
in quei primissimi anni
del regime fascista
la storia comincia
con le elezioni
del 6 aprile 1924
voi capite
è passato un anno e mezzo
dalla marcia su Roma
da un anno e mezzo
il cavalier Benito Mussolini
è stato incaricato dal re
di formare il governo
da un anno e mezzo
Mussolini è
presidente del consiglio
nonché
ministro degli interni
degli esteri
e della guerra
perché tiene tutto lui
comunque
formalmente
nel 1924
il regime fascista
non è ancora un regime
non è ancora una dittatura
voglio dire che ci sono ancora i partiti
compresi quelli di opposizione
i comunisti
i socialisti
c'è una stampa di opposizione
c'è un parlamento
dove si discute
ci sono le elezioni
salvo che tutto questo
è sotto l'ombra
della violenza
impunita
degli squadristi
per cui
c'è una stampa di opposizione
ma i giornalisti
vengono regolarmente
pestati
o ammazzati
e i giornali
le sedi dei giornali
devastate
c'è
c'è un parlamento
ci sono elezioni
ma tutto avviene
sotto il sedio del bastone
del manganello
dell'intimidazione
comunque
il 6 aprile
si va
alle elezioni
per la nuova camera
si vota solo
per la camera
sapete
il senato
è di nomina reggia
siedono in senato
tutti gli italiani
più illustri
a vita
nominati dal re
elezioni
per la camera
e il fascismo
si è comunque
garantito
la vittoria
in queste elezioni
come ha fatto
a garantirsi
la vittoria
intanto
il partito nazionale
fascista
non si presenta
alle elezioni
da solo
ma con una lista
nazionale
vastissima
subito
ribattezzata
il listone
Mussolini
che riunisce
i fascisti
quasi tutta la destra
ma anche i liberali
anche molti
cattolici
dopodiché
la legge elettorale
voi sapete
perché lo vediamo
anche noi
in tutti i giorni
che manovrando
la legge elettorale
si riesce
a condizionare
i risultati
in qualche misura
la legge elettorale
è la legge
acerbo
che dà
un premio
di maggioranza
i premi di maggioranza
sono cose
di cui si discute
anche oggi
il premio
di maggioranza
della legge
acerbo
è fatto
in questo modo
se una lista
arriva
al 25%
dei voti
avrà
i due terzi
dei seggi
in Parlamento
basta un quarto
dei voti
per avere
la maggioranza
assoluta
in Parlamento
già che c'è
la legge acerbo
prevede
che i partiti
possano mandare
squadre
di loro simpatizzanti
leggi
camice nere
a sorvegliare
i seggi
durante le operazioni
di voto
si vota
e va
come deve andare
non c'era neanche bisogno
della legge acerbo
il listone
Mussolini
prende
il 60%
dei voti
e ha
i due terzi
dei seggi
alla Camera
il 30 maggio
quasi due mesi
dopo le elezioni
la Camera
si riunisce
per confermare
i risultati
elettorali
e accogliere
i nuovi deputati
deve essere
una giornata
di festa
per Mussolini
è la giornata
che sancisce
il suo trionfo
ma c'è
un deputato
che rovina
la festa
e quel deputato
è Giacomo Matteotti
Giacomo Matteotti
deputato socialista
però
come dire
chi ha la mia età
si ricorda
che i socialisti
hanno sempre fatto
una gran fatica
a formare un unico partito
e restare tutti insieme
le scissioni
sono parte integrante
della storia
dei partiti socialisti
nel 1924
ci sono due diversi
partiti socialisti
in Italia
Giacomo Matteotti
è deputato
di uno dei due
che ironicamente
si chiama
il partito socialista
unitario
ed è nato
da una scissione
naturalmente
partito socialista
unitario
PSU
che Mussolini
il quale era
un grande giornalista
e ci sapeva fare
in queste cose
chiama
il PUS
e i suoi deputati
naturalmente
i PUSSisti
Giacomo Matteotti
è deputato
del partito
socialista
unitario
ed è
anche se
ancora giovane
è un socialista
di grandissima
esperienza
è uno che
si è fatto le ossa
con le lotte
dei braccianti
nel Polesine
lui viene da
quelle parti là
è uno che durante
la prima guerra mondiale
si è fatto degli anni
di confino
in Sicilia
perché si opponeva
alla guerra
è un socialista
appunto
è socialista
perché non è comunista
è contrario
alla dittatura sovietica
ai metodi
di Lenin
ma per il resto
è un uomo di sinistra
ed è un avversario
integrale
del fascismo
e Matteotti
quel giorno
il 30 maggio
interviene
alla Camera
per fare
l'elenco
di tutti gli abusi
le violazioni
le illegalità
le violenze
i pestaggi
in qualche caso
gli omicidi
che secondo lui
rendono non valide
le elezioni
è un discorso
documentato
preciso
pieno di fatti
di nomi
è un discorso
che dura
un'ora e mezza
non perché
Matteotti
prevedesse
di parlare
così a lungo
ma perché parla
continuamente
interrotto
alla Camera
dagli insulti
dalle grida
dei fascisti
da ululati
e minacce
col presidente
della Camera
un altro bel personaggio
della storia
d'Italia
Alfredo Rocco
grande giurista
e futuro autore
del codice Rocco
cioè del codice penale
fascista
che come qualcuno
ricorderà
poi dopo la guerra
l'Italia
si è portata dietro
ancora molto
a lungo
questo codice penale
autoritario
repressivo
fatto da questo
grande giurista
fascista
nazionalista
e fascista
che in quel momento
è il presidente
della Camera
e che continuamente
anche lui
interrompe
Matteotti
dicendo
onorevole
stringa
concluda
Matteotti
fa il suo elenco
di violenze
di abusi
di intimidazioni
di brogli
e conclude
dicendo
ma voi ci volete
ricacciare indietro
al tempo
delle dominazioni
straniere
è un'Italia
che si ricorda
ancora il risorgimento
l'hanno fatto
i padri
alla peggio
i nonni
se lo ricordano
ancora
voi ci volete
ci siamo appena
liberati
dagli austriaci
e voi ci volete
ricacciare
indietro
Matteotti
bene o male
riesce a finire
il suo discorso
torna a sedersi
nei banchi
della sinistra
e si rivolge
al deputato
che è seduto
vicino a lui
Cosattini
Giovanni
e Matteotti
gli dice
adesso
preparatevi
a fare
la mia
commemorazione
Cosattini
gli dice
ma non prendere
le cose
tanto in tragico
come reagisce
Mussolini
a questo discorso
di Matteotti
cosa sappiamo
di come reagisce
Mussolini
beh intanto
abbiamo delle
testimonianze
voi saprete
che le testimonianze
uno deve
prendere
per quello
che sono
cioè
magari
fossero sempre
tutte
noi abbiamo
una testimonianza
molto precisa
di un grande uomo
Emilio Lussu
il quale dice
che uscendo
dall'aula
quel giorno
Mussolini
ha detto
ai deputati
fascisti
se voi
non foste
dei vigliacchi
nessuno
avrebbe mai
osato
pronunziare
un discorso
simile
naturalmente
Emilio Lussu
è un grande uomo
un grande antifascista
all'epoca
è un deputato
del partito
sardo
d'azione
è anche
un eroe di guerra
due medaglie
d'argento
l'autore
di un libro
che chi ha la mia età
ha letto già a scuola
un anno
sull'altipiano
è un grande uomo
Emilio Lussu
naturalmente
è anche un grande
antifascista
va a sapere
se davvero
ha sentito
quelle parole
di Mussolini
cosa possiamo
sapere
di più sicuro
di testimonianze
su cosa ha detto
Mussolini
quella sera
ne incontreremo
ancora qualcuna
ma non è ancora
il momento
io adesso vi dico
invece cosa ha scritto
Mussolini
sul suo giornale
il primo giugno
Mussolini scrive
sul popolo
d'Italia
che alla camera
durante il discorso
dell'onorevole
Matteotti
la maggioranza
i fascisti
è stata fin
troppo paziente
cito
l'onorevole
Matteotti
ha tenuto
un discorso
mostruosamente
provocatorio
Mussolini
e Mussolini
dice
un discorso
quello di Matteotti
che avrebbe
meritato
qualcosa di più
di una risposta
verbale
cioè
hanno gridato
i nostri
hanno ululato
avrebbe meritato
qualcosa di più
d'altra parte
il tono
era quello
un mese prima
3 maggio
del 24
Mussolini
capo del governo
aveva scritto
sul suo giornale
il popolo
d'Italia
che Matteotti
era un mistificatore
un vigliacco
e un ruffiano
e che non doveva
poi lamentarsi
Matteotti
cito
tra virgolette
se dovesse
capitargli
di trovarsi
un giorno
o l'altro
con la testa
rotta
ma proprio
virgolette
fine della citazione
così scriveva
sul giornale
il capo
del governo
presidente
del consiglio
del regno
d'Italia
nell'anno
di Grazia
se poi
Mussolini
quel giorno
abbia detto
ai suoi
qualcosa
di più preciso
ne riparleremo
fatto sta
che passano
una decina
di giorni
e il 10 giugno
del 24
intorno alle 4
del pomeriggio
Matteotti
esce di casa
abitava a Roma
al Flaminio
via Pisanelli
esce di casa
per andare
a piedi
a Montecitorio
la mattina
era stato
a Montecitorio
in biblioteca
e tornato
a casa
per pranzo
a quell'epoca
tutti tornavano
a casa
per pranzo
nessuno mangiava
fuori
c'erano
il bar
la gente
tornava a casa
per pranzo
dove la moglie
aveva preparato
il pranzo
la moglie
o la cuoca
e poi tornava
in ufficio
al pomeriggio
Matteotti
esce verso le 4
per tornare
a Montecitorio
in bocca
in lungo
Tevere
Arnaldo
da Brescia
alla camera
non c'è mai
arrivato
e quella sera
non è tornato
a casa
subito
non se ne è accorto
nessuno
tranne la moglie
che la sera
non vede
che non ci sono
i telefonini
Matteotti
la sera
non torna a casa
la moglie
lo aspetta
tutta la sera
tutta la notte
alla finestra
non torna
il giorno dopo
11 giugno
la moglie
di Matteotti
decide che deve
fare qualcosa
da chi va
la moglie
di un deputato
socialista
che quella
notte
non è tornato
a casa
va alla questura
no che non va
alla questura
va al partito
dai dirigenti
socialisti
e dice
ma oh
sapete qualcosa
di mio marito
i socialisti
che erano
gente legalitaria
mica come i comunisti
socialisti
erano gente legalitaria
vanno in questura
a denunciare
la scomparsa
di Matteotti
già quel pomeriggio
Filippo Turati
che è il più famoso
dei capi socialisti
scrive alla sua donna
Anna Kulishoff
che non è a Roma
per nostra fortuna
così loro si scrivono
e noi oggi abbiamo
le loro lettere
Turati
già quel pomeriggio
dell'11 giugno
il giorno dopo
la scomparsa
scrive ad Anna Kulishoff
dice
l'ipotesi più probabile
è che sia stato vittima
di un sequestro
di persona
come del resto
gli avvenne
già nel Polesine
vi dico subito
di cosa sta parlando
di un sequestro
di persona
se non di peggio
scrive Turati
ed è straordinario
che Turati
già quel primo giorno
aggiunga
certo non è verosimile
che un delitto
sia stato organizzato
dal governo
ne risentirebbe
troppo danno
in altre parole
la prima cosa
che viene in mente
a tutti
è che se Matteotti
è sparito
sia stato il governo
che lo ha fatto sparire
però poi Turati
dice ma figurati
uno scandalo simile
non sono mica scemi
non è possibile
cosa voleva dire
quando dice
come già gli accadde
in Polesine
è una storia poco chiara
perché alla vigilia
delle elezioni
del 21
tre anni prima
Matteotti
dalle sue parti
nel Polesine
era stato rapito
dagli squadristi
portato in aperta
campagna
e lì aveva subito
delle violenze
su cui non aveva mai
raccontato niente
di preciso
però correvano
molte voci
anche di violenze
sessuali
da parte degli squadristi
che l'avevano rapito
tuttora non si sa
se erano vanterie
dei fascisti
comunque fatto sa
che tutti sapevano
che gli era successa
questa cosa
comunque è sparito
lo cercano
per tutto l'undici
e poi ancora il dodici
si organizzano ricerche
come sempre succede
in questi casi
chi c'era
si ricorda
il delitto Moro
tutti i giorni
l'hanno visto
in quel posto
in quell'altro
il lago della Ducchesi
messa ecco
battute
ecco lo stesso per Matteotti
l'hanno gettato
nel lago di Vico
corrono al lago di Vico
non c'è niente
l'undici
il dodici
la sera del dodici
Mussolini
deve rispondere
alla camera
perché
tutti si stanno chiedendo
cos'è successo
a Matteotti
e Mussolini
naturalmente
alla camera dice
ma
credo che la camera
cito eh
sia ansiosa
di avere notizie
sulla sorte
dell'onorevole
Matteotti
dice Mussolini
non si può escludere
un delitto
e se fosse
dice Mussolini
alla camera
non potrebbe
non suscitare
lo sdegno
e la commozione
del governo
e del Parlamento
e il Mussolini
per bene
l'assicurante
e legalitario
che prende
le distanze
non tutti
la bevono
Mussolini
fa questo intervento
poi non parla più
la camera
continua a discutere
ansiosamente
Mussolini
non parla più
un deputato
repubblicano
ci sono anche
i repubblicani
nel Parlamento
del Regno
d'Italia
naturalmente
è un paese
democratico
ancora
un deputato
repubblicano
chiesa
visto che
il dibattito
va avanti
e Mussolini
non interviene più
il deputato
chiesa
grida
perché il governo
non interviene
tace
e complice
potete immaginare
rissa
violentissima
alla camera
complice
volano le poltrone
seduta
sospesa
però sta di fatto
che in quei due
primi giorni
11 e 12 giugno
alla camera
nei corridoi
si scherza
anche un po'
ma chissà
dove è andato
Matteotti
Turati
scrive
alla
Kulishov
no
conoscendo
Matteotti
è escluso
che potesse
cito
trattarsi
di un'avventura
donnesca
se Turati
lo esclude
è perché
gliel'hanno detto
dice ma non è che
Matteotti
ha detto
alla moglie
vado a comprare
le sigarette
poi ecco
perché si sa
come vanno
queste cose
e il 12 giugno
per l'appunto
un giornale
di cui
riparleremo
che si chiama
il Corriere Italiano
il 12 giugno
scrive
che Matteotti
sembra una barzelletta
è uscito
dicendo alla moglie
che andava a comprare
le sigarette
e che la moglie
lo ha cercato
nelle tabaccherie
vicine
e nessuno
l'aveva visto
e che non è la prima volta
che Matteotti
si allontana
senza avvisare la moglie
ecco
tutto questo
sul Corriere Italiano
allora
adesso mi spiace per voi
ma vi devo fare
una lezioncina
su cos'era il Corriere Italiano
perché vedrete
che la cosa c'entra
Mussolini
l'anno prima
presidente del consiglio
da pochi mesi
aveva deciso
che voleva avere
un giornale
ma lui aveva un giornale
il popolo d'Italia
ma non basta
voleva avere
un giornale
indipendente
che però
fosse filo governativo
e incarica
un suo uomo di fiducia
di organizzare
la creazione
di questo nuovo giornale
l'uomo di fiducia
è un personaggio
importantissimo
di cui parleremo
parecchio stasera
si chiama
Aldo Finzi
ed è in quel momento
il sottosegretario
agli interni
cioè il ministro
dell'interno
perché il ministro
sulla carta
è Mussolini
ve l'ho detto
il suo sottosegretario
che gestisce
il ministero
dell'interno
è Aldo Finzi
Aldo Finzi
che è un ragazzo
di 32 anni
sono tutti giovani
e vedrete
i protagonisti
di questa storia
Aldo Finzi
è ebreo
da parte di padre
invece la madre
è cattolica
appartiene
all'alta borghesia
veneta
anzi
è del Polesine
anche lui
è nato
a pochi chilometri
da dove è nato
Matteotti
nel Polesine
Finzi
è di grande famiglia
borghese
agrari
molto ricchi
ha sposato
la nipote
di un cardinale
benché sia ebreo
di nascita
ma di fatto
è convertito
è stato pilota
da caccia
nella prima guerra mondiale
ha fatto il volo
su Vienna
famoso
con d'annunzio
Aldo Finzi
è campione
motociclista
un tipico
giovane
dell'alta borghesia
moderna
modernissima
futurista
di quell'epoca
ovviamente
fascista
della prima ora
deputato
fascista
fra gli organizzatori
della marcia
su Roma
a lui
al suo fedele
sottosegretario
Aldo Finzi
Mussolini
da ordine
e finanziamenti
per fondare
un nuovo giornale
Finzi
si dà da fare
trova i finanziamenti
ulteriori
chi finanzia
gli industriali del nord
Milano
Torino
la Fiat
e crea un giornale
che deve fare concorrenza
al Corriere della Sera
Corriere della Sera
è il grande giornale
d'opinione
della borghesia italiana
il nuovo giornale
si chiamerà
il Corriere
Italiano
fanno un bellissimo giornale
chiamano tutti gli intellettuali
più in voga
del momento
la terza pagina
la dirige
Ardengo Soffici
collaborano
Prezzolini
Palazzeschi
Savinio
Cardarelli
Achille Campanile
come direttore
del Corriere Italiano
mettono
un altro personaggio
che mi spiace dirvelo
ma vi devo raccontare
chi era
lo incontreremo
si chiama
Filippo Filippelli
è uno che è nato nel 90
anche lui
ha 33 anni
34 anni
tutti giovani
Filippelli
è un avvocato
giornalista
scrive sul popolo
d'Italia
il giornale di Mussolini
dopo la marcia
su Roma
è diventato
segretario
di Arnaldo
Mussolini
sapete
il fratello
intellettuale
di Benito
Filippelli
è uno che ha le mani
in pasta
in un sacco di affari
ha delle conoscenze
tra gli industriali
torinesi
genovesi
è uno che gestisce
tangenti
per il partito
fascista
e per il popolo
d'Italia
che è diretto
da Arnaldo
Mussolini
tutto si tiene
Filippo Filippelli
viene fatto
direttore
di questo nuovo giornale
è il Corriere Italiano
è il giornale
che il 12 giugno
due giorni dopo
la scomparsa
di Matteotti
pubblica questo articolo
dicendo sì
Matteotti
le fa queste cose
ha detto la moglie
che andava a comprare
le sigarette
si sa come sono
queste cose
ma intanto
la questura
di Roma
sta facendo
indagini
e le indagini
si rivelano
straordinariamente
facili
quello stesso
12 giugno
testimoni
oculari
raccontano
quello che è successo
in Lungotevere
Arnaldo da Brescia
c'era il passante
c'era l'inquilino
che prendeva il fresco
alla finestra
hanno visto tutti
cinque individui
avevano sollevato
e caricato
su un'automobile
un uomo
che si divincolava
e chiedeva aiuto
prendendolo a pugni
l'auto
si è diretta
verso Ponte Milvio
ed è sparita
poi trovano
due ragazzini
che stavano giocando
sul Lungotevere
e i due ragazzini
dicono
è certo che l'abbiamo vista
la macchina
sono scesi
in cinque
e i ragazzini
si erano avvicinati
alla macchina
l'automobile
è ancora un bene di lusso
capite naturalmente
però per i ragazzini
è una cosa
che ti attrae enormemente
infatti i ragazzini
sono andati
hanno visto
questa macchina
fermarsi
sono scesi
questi cinque
i ragazzini
vanno a vedere
dice ci hanno allontanati
bruscamente
dicendo
toglietevi
dai piedi
mentre gli altri testimoni
hanno detto
ah una bella macchina
i ragazzini
sanno perfettamente
che marca era
una lancia lambda
bellissima
nera
elegante
chiusa
e poi dicono
i ragazzini
è arrivato Matteotti
dice come è arrivato Matteotti
eh
sono del quartiere
lui abita lì
lo conoscono tutti
è arrivato Matteotti
e lui
gli sono saltati
addosso
in due
Matteotti
si è divincolato
ne ha buttato uno
per terra
sono arrivati gli altri
l'han preso a pugni
in faccia
nella pancia
l'han caricato
a bordo
e sono partiti
dunque era una macchina
una lancia
lambda nera
ce ne saranno tante
non c'è problema
ci sono i portinai
del
casamento
lì accanto
che già la sera
prima
hanno notato
quest'automobile
che si aggirava
nella zona
essendo portinai
coscienziosi
hanno preso
il numero di targa
l'hanno poi rivista
il giorno dopo
è di nuovo lì
la stessa macchina
numero di targa
andiamo a cercare
questa macchina
non ci mettono niente
a trovarla
è un'automobile
che appartiene
a un garage
che la dà in affitto
ah
è stata data in affitto
eh sì
quando
qualche giorno fa
il 6 giugno
ah
e chi l'ha presa
in affitto
il direttore
del Corriere Italiano
Filippo Filippelli
è venuto lui
a ritirarla
no non è venuto subito
è venuto uno
il 9
a ritirarla
chi è?
è un giornalista
del Corriere Italiano
che si chiama
Amerigo Dumini
questo Amerigo Dumini
che è
il principale personaggio
del delitto Matteotti
è il capo
di quelli
che l'hanno ammazzato
anche se non è chiaro
se l'abbia ammazzato lui
di persona
forse no
ma comunque è il capo
Amerigo Dumini
è un personaggio
straordinario
è da romanzo
e uno
vabbè la cosa non vi stupirà
è giovane
certo
è nato nel 94
ha 30 anni
in quei 30 anni
ha già fatto di tutto
perché è nato
pensate negli Stati Uniti
il padre era un fiorentino
emigrato lì
un pittore
la mamma inglese
Dumini
è nato negli Stati Uniti
quindi ha la cittadinanza americana
però poi sono tornati in Italia
già prima della grande guerra
scoppiata la grande guerra
lui si è arruolato volontario
eroe di guerra
ferito
mutilato di guerra
nel dopoguerra
si è buttato
con i fascisti
ha fatto carriera
fra gli squadristi
ha partecipato
a parecchi omicidi
secondo Emilio Lussu
che però lo sappiamo
insomma
è un antifascista
non ci si può sempre fidare
comunque secondo Emilio Lussu
Amerigo Dumini
amava presentarsi
dicendo
Dumini
nove omicidi
formalmente però
fa il giornalista
al Corriere Italiano
questo galantuomo
e quindi
ha la tessera della stampa
frequenta Montecitorio
nella tribuna
dei giornalisti
è di casa
al Viminale
il Viminale
non è soltanto
il Ministero dell'Interno
come oggi
ma è anche
la Presidenza del Consiglio
tanto è sempre Mussolini
sia Presidente del Consiglio
sia Ministro
è di casa
anche a Palazzo Chigi
dove all'epoca
c'era il Ministero degli Esteri
ma tanto il Ministro
è Mussolini
quindi
Dumini è di casa
dappertutto
Mussolini lo conosce bene
lo vedono
pacche sulle spalle
caro Dumini
come va
tant'è vero
che Dumini
oltre allo stipendio
di giornalista
del Corriere Italiano
prende anche
un altro stipendio
dalla Presidenza
del Consiglio
dall'ufficio stampa
della Presidenza
del Consiglio
diretto
da un altro
galantuomo
di cui per adesso
vi faccio solo il nome
ma ne riparleremo
capo dell'ufficio stampa
del Viminale
che si chiama
Cesarino Rossi
dunque
Dumini è quello
che ha ritirato l'auto
il 9
il giorno prima
e sì
non solo
salta fuori subito
la ritirata
il 9
e la sera del 10
la portate indietro
al garage
no
al Viminale
quella sera lì
è arrivato il Viminale
con questa macchina
erano in 5
a bordo
e i carabinieri
di guardia
li hanno identificati
tutti e 5
è andato a parlare
con qualcuno
e poi è ripartito
la questura
non potendo fare altro
spicca
i mandati di cattura
per Dumini
per gli altri quattro
e per Filippelli
direttore del Corriere Italiano
non trovano nessuno
tutti spariti
però Dumini lo trovano
perché è rimasto
un po' in ritardo
Filippelli è sparito proprio
lo beccano poi
qualche giorno dopo
ne riparleremo
i quattro compagnoni
hanno preso un treno
presto per il nord
e sono andati a Milano
Dumini
ha fatto un po' tardi
lo prendono la sera del 12
a Termini
che stava per salire
sul treno per Milano
anche lui
lo arrestano
e lo portano a Regina Celi
gli altri quattro
peraltro
li acchiappano
nei giorni successivi
al nord
e Dumini
fin dai primi interrogatori
racconta
quello che è successo
e dice
sì certo
l'abbiamo acchiappato noi
Matteotti
eh
volevamo dargli
una bella lezione
sto cretino
c'è morto di paura
in macchina
ha avuto un malore
uno sbocco di sangue
effettivamente
la macchina è piena di sangue
gli è venuto un malore
beh vi anticipo
perché non credo
che arriveremo a parlarne dopo
che Dumini
è stato poi processato
di nuovo dopo la guerra
dalla Repubblica Italiana
e nel 47
al processo
Dumini
darà una versione diversa
no no
dice
il mio braccio destro
Albino Volpi
si chiama
lo ha pugnalato
in macchina
Matteotti
ma noi non volevamo eh
solo che Matteotti
si divincolava
gli ha tirato un calcio
a Volpi
Volpi ha perso la testa
e l'ha ammazzato
questa è l'ultima versione
di Dumini
dopodiché dice
certo dovevamo liberarci
del cadavere
abbiamo girato
per la campagna romana
in quel pomeriggio
e se era
del 10 giugno
cercavano un posto
per bruciare
il cadavere
poi si sono resi conto
che non era tanto pratico
meglio seppellirlo
vanno in un bosco
scaviamo un buco
non ci abbiamo niente
col cric
della macchina
scavano un buco
portano via
la giacca
il passaporto
la borsa
di Matteotti
lo ficcano
dentro il buco
tornano a Roma
e vanno al Viminale
vanno al Viminale
poi da lì
gli dicono
sgombrate
dove vanno
e vanno da Filippelli
direttore del Corriere Italiano
dove devono andare
è lui che ha preso la macchina
Filippelli
si vede arrivare
questi 5 deficienti
con la macchina
piena di sangue
si mette le mani
nei capelli
e che facciamo
della macchina
per fortuna
c'è il caporedattore
del Corriere Italiano
che ha un garage
mettiamola nel tuo garage
dove il 12
la polizia
la ritrova
quindi
la sera del 12
hanno tutti i nomi
hanno arrestato
Domini
hanno trovato la macchina
quella notte
ai vertici
del governo italiano
non dorme nessuno
a luna di notte
al Viminale
si tiene una riunione
a cui partecipano
quattro persone
due delle quali
in seguito
ci hanno raccontato
di questa riunione
ciascuno a modo suo
perché che cose
ho detto io
e cosa ha detto lui
ognuno se lo ricorda
a modo suo
ma che ci sia stata
la riunione
non ci sono dubbi
chi sono questi quattro
quattro uomini
ai vertici
dello Stato italiano
uno è Aldo Finzi
lo conoscete già
eroe di guerra
e sottosegretario
agli interni
il secondo
è il capo
della polizia
il generale
Emilio De Bono
De Bono è l'unico
fra i protagonisti
della nostra storia
che non è più un ragazzo
c'è 58 anni
ma ne dimostra di più
non so se vi ricordate
le foto di De Bono
alla marcia su Roma
è uno dei quadrumbiri
della marcia su Roma
De Bono
con una gran barba bianca
anche lui
eroe di guerra
generale dell'esercito
tre medaglie d'argento
ha aderito al fascismo
Mussolini
lo ha nominato
capo della polizia
e contemporaneamente
capo della milizia
cioè l'esercito privato
ma riconosciuto
e pagato dallo Stato
del partito fascista
De Bono occupa
entrambe le poltrone
tutto il potere esecutivo
ce l'ha lui
il terzo uomo
è Cesarino Rossi
il capo dell'ufficio stampa
uno di quelli
che pagavano
lo stipendio a Dumini
capo dell'ufficio stampa
della presidenza
del consiglio
Cesarino Rossi
è un
sì
giovane anche lui
non più giovanissimo
ha 37 anni
è uno che ha un passato
come quello di Mussolini
Cesarino Rossi
è stato socialista
è stato un dirigente
socialista
un sindacalista
di sinistra
poi nel 14
quando è scoppiata
la prima guerra mondiale
come Mussolini
si è buttato
con gli interventisti
e quindi
è scivolato a destra
Mussolini
l'ha chiamato
al popolo d'Italia
nel 19
quando nascono
i facci di combattimento
Cesarino Rossi
è uno dei fondatori
è membro del Gran Consiglio
del Fascismo
vice segretario
del partito
e capo
dell'ufficio stampa
della presidenza
del consiglio
quindi
Finzi
De Bono
Rossi
il quarto uomo
vi devo infliggere anche lui
abbiate pazienza
ma spero sia l'ultimo
Giovanni Marinelli
è meno conosciuto
anche lui è un vecchio socialista
che però poi
ha seguito Mussolini
anche lui
è tra i fondatori
del fascio
e adesso Giovanni Marinelli
è il segretario
amministrativo
del partito
fascista
ripeto
badate
segretario
amministrativo
del partito
fascista
l'uomo
che maneggia
i soldi
compresi
i fondi neri
questi quattro
gentiluomini
si incontrano
a luna di notte
al Viminale
sede della presidenza
del consiglio
del ministero
dell'interno
e discutono
tutta la notte
perché la situazione
dato che è stato
arrestato
Dumini
è drammatica
perché la situazione
di cosa hanno paura
hanno paura
che Dumini
parli
e che si scopra
l'esistenza
di quella
che veniva
chiamata
la
ceca
fascista
ovvero
la ceca
del Viminale
cosa vuol dire
la ceca
oggi non lo sa più
nessuno
nel 1924
lo sapevano tutti
la ceca
era la polizia
segreta di Lenin
segreta
del regime
sovietico
era
celebre
nel mondo
per
le atrocità
e così via
tutti conoscevano
questa sigla
i fascisti
si sono fatti
la loro ceca
che però
direi vero
non è tanto
una polizia segreta
è piuttosto
una specie
oggi lo chiameremmo
uno squadrone
della morte
è un gruppetto
di killer
e di picchiatori
tutti reclutati
fra gli arditi
milanesi
seguaci più fedeli
di Mussolini
quasi tutti
anche delinquenti
abituali
già schedati
per rapina
furto
e così via
il capo
Edumini
gli altri
sono sei o sette
personaggi
ben noti
alle questure
i quali
grazie al ministero
dell'interno
e al capo
della polizia
generale
De Bono
sono tutti dotati
di passaporti falsi
porti d'arme
con nomi falsi
tessere di libera
circolazione
sulla rete ferroviaria
tutto rilasciato
ufficialmente
dalle autorità
di pubblica sicurezza
sono alloggiati
a Roma
spesati di tutto
in un albergo
in via del corso
vicino palazzo Chigi
e sono a disposizione
quando c'è bisogno
di qualche missione
speciale
basta dirlo
al camerata
Dumini
ora
è un gruppo segreto
la ceca fascista
ma mica tanto
in realtà
lo sanno anche
quelli dell'opposizione
che i fascisti
hanno questo gruppetto
di killer
come facciamo io
noi a saperlo
perché ne parla
Turati
nelle sue lettere
alla Kulishov
Turati
scrive
alla Kulishov
che
ora che si parla
della scomparsa
di Matteotti
salta fuori
il nome
dice Turati
del famigerato
Dumini
ispettore
dei fascisti
fuori ruolo
tipo
Albino Volpi
è quello che
secondo Dumini
ha poi pugnalato
Matteotti
i fascisti
fuori ruolo
cioè insomma
segreti
no ma mica
tanto segreti
lo sanno tutti
che ci sono
però un conto
è sapere
che ci sono
e un conto
è sapere
che Mussolini
ha ordinato lui
la formazione
di questo gruppo
e che sono loro
che hanno rapito
Matteotti
quindi
Finzi
De Bono
Rossi
e Marinelli
perché sono lì
ma perché in realtà
sono loro
i capi
del gruppo
sono loro
che gestiscono
la ceca
e lo diranno
tutte e due
interrogati
durante l'istruttoria
perché finiranno
in galera tutti
questi troppo un po'
tutti no ma insomma
vedrete
Rossi
e Marinelli
diranno tutti e due
o meglio
voi capite
Rossi dirà
il capo e Marinelli
e Marinelli
dirà il capo e Rossi
ma comunque
è chiarissimo
che tutti e due
hanno le mani in pasta
in questa cosa
Rossi dice
certo la nostra ceca
certo che esiste
la nostra ceca
e Marinelli
chiedete a lui
in realtà noi abbiamo
anche corrispondenza
amministrativa
e Marinelli
mette i soldi
che paga gli alberghi
e tutto quanto
a questa brava gente
e Rossi
è quello che
trasmette
gli ordini
ora
certo
siamo tutti
spaventatissimi
se Dumini
parla
si mette male
ma la cosa
più grave
qual è
è il rischio
che tiri
dentro
lui
cosa hanno detto
quella sera
secondo De Bono
Rossi
dice
bisogna farlo
liberare
Dumini
l'hanno arrestato
fallo liberare
tu sei il capo
della polizia
fallo mettere fuori
cito
se no
quelli
dicono tutto
De Bono
che fa
l'ingenuo
sostiene
di aver detto
dicono tutto
tutto cosa
e Rossi
a questo punto
gli avrebbe detto
ma che è il presidente
che l'ha ordinato
secondo De Bono
lui avrebbe risposto
indignato
ma figurati
se Mussolini
c'entra
con questa cosa
secondo Finzi
invece
De Bono
quando Rossi
dice
è il presidente
che l'ha ordinato
secondo Finzi
De Bono
dice
quel benedetto
uomo
non ha mai voluto
ascoltare
consigli di moderazione
naturalmente
a voi piacerebbe
come piacerebbe
a me
sapere con certezza
se Mussolini
l'ha ordinato
o anche solo
se lo sapeva
devo dire che
oggi gli storici
sono abbastanza convinti
come minimo
che sapesse
a rigore
proprio
la prova
in assoluto
non c'è
sembra
più o meno
sicuro
che loro
fossero convinti
di fare
un grande favore
a Mussolini
togliendo
di mezzo
Matteotti
ma la prova
provata
che Mussolini
abbia detto
espressamente
fatemelo fuori
non c'è
c'è un dettaglio
che non vuol dire
niente
per quanto riguarda
le certezze
che noi possiamo avere
ma che psicologicamente
è interessante
ancora vent'anni
dopo
a Salò
Mussolini
continuerà a dire
io non c'entro
non sapevo
niente
Mussolini
a Salò
negli ultimi mesi
della sua vita
rilascia
molte ore
di intervista
a un giornalista
in cui è chiarissimo
che sta costruendo
la sua immagine
per il futuro
non dico
per i posteri
speravo ancora
di calarsela
però comunque
per il futuro
e a questo giornalista
Mussolini
che a Salò
vuole consegnare
alla storia
la sua verità
dice
io non c'entravo
non ne sapevo
niente
questo non significa
che sia vero
ovviamente
però
è interessante
era ossessionato
ancora
da questa cosa
e voleva
che si pensasse
che lui
non c'entrava niente
conta poco
nel senso
che Mussolini
ne ha già tante
sulle spalle
questa in più
o in meno
onestamente
non è che cambi
tanto
però
sarebbe bello
saperlo
i nostri quattro
a Palazzo
no a Palazzo Chigi
scusate
al Viminale
quella notte
sono tutti convinti
che lui
non solo sa
ma è lui
che ci ha detto
di farlo
e allora
che facciamo
far liberare
Dumini
dopo che è stato
formalmente arrestato
non si può
ma De Bono
si precipita
a Termini
dove Dumini
è ancora trattenuto
in attesa
di trasferirlo
a Regina Celi
De Bono
capo della polizia
si precipita
a Termini
si chiude
con Dumini
in una stanza
e parlano
loro due
da soli
Dumini
più tardi
ai giudici
che gli chiedono
che ti ha detto
il generale De Bono
Dumini dirà
mi ha garantito
che
i miei amici
non sarebbero
stati arrestati
e che anche a me
mi avrebbero messo fuori
al più presto possibile
e mi ha detto
dice Dumini
il generale De Bono
mi ha detto
neghi
io voglio salvare
il fascismo
quando Dumini
racconta queste cose
ai giudici
tempo dopo
è furibondo
perché non l'hanno
messo fuori
è ancora dentro
e sta per andare
sotto processo
tant'è vero
che odia tutti
Dumini
in quel momento
per la serie
l'ingratitudine
che comincia qui
Dumini
è stato quel porco
del generale De Bono
che ci ha fatti arrestare
proseguiamo
con l'ingratitudine
cosa fa Mussolini
Mussolini
dopo pochissimi giorni
comincia a organizzarsi
per farsi il vuoto intorno
e tagliare i legami
con tutti quelli
che possono essere compromessi
in questa faccenda
il 14 giugno
chiama a casa sua
in via Rasella
ah già perché Mussolini
abitava in via Rasella
dove c'è stato poi
l'attentato
nel 44
nello stesso palazzo Tittoni
davanti alla quale
Sassà Bentivegna
ha portato la bomba
abitava lì
e Mussolini
chiama a casa sua
il 14 giugno
in via Rasella
il capo dell'ufficio stampa
Cesare Rossi
e gli dice
caro Rossi
capirai che
date le circostanze
devi fare un passo indietro
dimettiti
lo stesso giorno
chiama a casa sua
il suo vice
al ministero dell'interno
Aldo Finzi
e gli dice
caro Finzi
capirai che
visto le circostanze
devi fare un passo indietro
dimettiti
Cesare Rossi
e Aldo Finzi
capiscono subito
che rischiano
di pagare tutto loro
Mussolini
ha bisogno di capri espiatori
li sta liquidando
loro devono tutto a Mussolini
però anche lì
la gratitudine reciproca
non è proprio
la massima
delle loro qualità
cosa fanno
quel 14 giugno
tornando da casa
di Mussolini
Cesare Rossi
e Aldo Finzi
ognuno va a casa
e comincia
a scrivere
un memoriale
in cui
racconta
tutto
Cesare Rossi
scrive un memoriale
in cui racconta
della ceca
e dei crimini
compiuti
dalla ceca
per ordine
di Mussolini
dice che lui
Cesare Rossi
non c'entra niente
e che la colpa
di tutto è Mussolini
anche per Matteotti
perché Cesare Rossi
ecco
l'unica testimonianza
su cosa avrebbe detto
Mussolini
quel giorno famoso
dopo il discorso
di Matteotti
alla Camera
dobbiamo credergli
e va a sapere
e voi capite
questo è il mestiere
dello storico
la gente ti dice
è successo questo
e tu dici
che faccio
gli credo
o non gli credo
Cesare Rossi
dice
Mussolini
quella sera
mi ha detto
cosa fa
questa ceca
che fa
Dumini
quell'uomo
Matteotti
dopo quel discorso
non dovrebbe
più circolare
questa è la verità
di Cesare Rossi
il quale dice
già altre volte
Mussolini
aveva ordinato
di far fuori qualcuno
ora Rossi
scrive tutto questo
nero su bianco
in un memoriale
poi scrive
una lettera
a Mussolini
in cui gli dice
che lui
Cesare Rossi
non intende
fare il capo espiatorio
di questa faccenda
perciò
ha scritto
un memoriale
e lo ha consegnato
a persone di fiducia
che lo pubblicheranno
se a lui
dovesse
capitare qualcosa
ma non dice
mica capitare
qualcosa
Cesare Rossi
dice
il capo
dell'ufficio stampa
della presidenza
del consiglio
che scrive
al presidente
del consiglio
e gli dice
se il cinismo
spaventevole
di cui hai dato
prova
fino ad oggi
ti inducesse
a ordinare
la mia
soppressione
fisica
gli dice
nero
su bianco
guarda
che se
mi fai
ammazzare
viene fuori
tutto
peraltro
il memoriale
rossi
salterà
poi fuori
non si capisce
come
ma alla fine
dell'anno
finirà
in mano
all'opposizione
e sarà
pubblicato
sul mondo
di Giovanni
Amendola
un altro
di quelli
che di lì a poco
saranno ammazzati
abbastonati
dai fascisti
ma sono
gli ultimi giorni
della libertà
di stampa
non farà in tempo
a cambiare le cose
questo è Cesare Rossi
e Aldo Finzi
anche Aldo Finzi
tornato a casa
scrive un memoriale
questo non lo conosciamo
non è mai saltato fuori
ma si sa che l'ha scritto
l'ha poi confermato
suo fratello
dice il fratello
sì sì
Aldo
ha scritto un memoriale
raccontava tutto
della ceca
che era Rossi
che lo gestiva
e io
dice Finzi
finanziavo
con i fondi
del ministero
dell'interno
per ordine
di Mussolini
dopodiché
Finzi
scrive
questo memoriale
contatta
una serie
di giornalisti
e di politici
dell'opposizione
dicendo
guardate
io ho depositato
questo memoriale
se dovesse
capitarmi qualcosa
tiratelo fuori
fa leggere
il memoriale
anche a un altro
dei capi fascisti
Dino Grandi
vicepresidente
della Camera
Dino Grandi
è quello che nel 43
farà cadere Mussolini
ricordate
il gran consiglio
l'ordine del giorno
Grandi
ma adesso
è un fedelissimo
a Dino Grandi
e sono compagnoni
fino a quel momento
ma Finzi
è stato appena licenziato
e a Dino Grandi
Finzi dice
guarda ci sono
sette copie diverse
del mio memoriale
depositate
in sette posti diversi
se mi capita
qualcosa
vedete che compagnia
di galantuomini
anche lui
se mi capita
qualcosa
il memoriale
salterà fuori
dunque
e Filippelli
direttore
del Corriere Italiano
l'uomo che aveva
affittato la macchina
e poi l'aveva nascosta
Filippelli
che è ricercato
è ricercato
e latitante
Filippelli
va da Cesarino Rossi
al Viminale
chiedendogli
cosa deve fare
Rossi
gli risponde
di cercarsi
un avvocato
a questo punto
Filippelli
torna a casa
e
la cosa vi stupirà
scrive un memoriale
in cui racconta
della cieca fascista
diretta da Rossi
che sono loro
che hanno assassinato
Matteotti
che tutti sapevano tutto
De Bono
Finzi
Rossi
Marinelli
e Mussolini
era il mandante
Filippelli scrive
che Dumini
è sempre al Viminale
è sempre con Mussolini
e lui
lui ha prestato
una macchina
degli amici
anche questo
memoriale di Filippelli
ce l'abbiamo
perché è saltato fuori
è stato pubblicato
all'estero
dai Rosselli
nel 25
poi
no non all'estero
ancora a Firenze
proprio gli ultimissimi
gli ultimissimi momenti
della libertà di stampa
dopodiché
Filippelli
nascosto anche lui
il suo memoriale
decide di fuggire
all'estero
non è così importante
ma ve lo racconto
lo stesso
è una vita avventurosa
quella di questa gente
arriva a Nervi
e il 17 giugno
si imbarca su un motoscafo
armato di pistola
sperando di arrivare
nel Principato di Monaco
invece lo ferma
la Guardia di Finanza
a largo
e lo riportano
in manette
a Roma
due giorni dopo
il Corriere Italiano
cessa le pubblicazioni
Mussolini
non ha mica finito
il 18 giugno
convoca anche
De Bono
capo della polizia
e gli fa dare
le dimissioni
da capo della polizia
lo stesso giorno
viene mandato via
il questore di Roma
lo stesso giorno
il 18 giugno
è arrestato Marinelli
come mandante
il 22 giugno
si costituisce
Cesare Rossi
a questo punto
sono tutti in galera
e il momento
politicamente
voi capite
potrebbe essere
terribile
per il fascismo
perché l'impressione
è veramente enorme
tenete conto
che nessuno sa
cosa è successo
a Matteotti
sì
Dumini
in quei giorni
in quelle settimane
dice
se sì
c'è morto in macchina
ma non l'ha mica trovato
però
la tensione
è enorme
nel paese
Mussolini
alla camera
è costretto
continuamente
a rispondere
a interrogazioni
su cosa è successo
e se il governo
c'entra qualcosa
e Mussolini
alla camera
dice
ma figuratevi
ma
soltanto
un nemico
che per anni
avesse pensato
a fare qualcosa
di diabolico
contro di me
poteva fare
questo delitto
per far ricadere
la colpa
su di me
questo delitto
dice Mussolini
che ci percuote
di orrore
e ci strappa
grida
di indignazione
però intanto
dice
conseguenze politiche
però no
perché conseguenze politiche
il governo
dimettersi
e perché mai
il governo
non si dimette
il 13 giugno
la moglie
di Matteotti
velia
va da Mussolini
a Palazzo Chigi
eccellenza
sono venuta
a chiederle
la salma
di mio marito
Mussolini
non si scompone
non si stupisce
neanche
che la moglie
del rapito
venga a chiedere
a lui
di restituirglielo
al contrario
dice signora
io vorrei restituirle
suo marito
vivo
forse un filo
di speranza
c'è ancora
nel partito
fascista
e in genere
nella destra
c'è chi comincia
a dire che Mussolini
farebbe meglio
a dimettersi
ma il 16 giugno
Mussolini
è ricevuto
dal re
al Quirinale
sapete che il Quirinale
era la residenza
del re
naturalmente
prima di diventare
quella del presidente
della repubblica
Vittorio Emanuele III
riceve Mussolini
al Quirinale
incontro
cordialissimo
Mussolini
ne esce
molto rafforzato
politicamente
e devo dire
che con tante cose
che si dicono
a carico
di Vittorio Emanuele III
questa qua
non viene mai menzionata
ma ha contribuito
fortemente
a aiutare
Mussolini
a uscire
da quel momento
potenzialmente
pericoloso
pochi giorni dopo
a Bologna
Dino Grandi
sempre lui
convoca
una grande
adunata
di fascisti
50.000 fascisti
in piazza
a sostegno
di Mussolini
e il 26 giugno
Mussolini
chiede la fiducia
in Senato
e la ottiene
quasi
all'unanimità
225 voti
a favore
su 252
la stragrande
maggioranza
dei senatori
anche non fascisti
in quel momento
di sbandamento
di panico
decide
di privilegiare
la continuità
e tutto
e vota
a favore
di Mussolini
anche Benedetto Croce
senatore
e che poi
diventerà
di lì a poco
uno dei leader
dell'antifascismo
anche Benedetto Croce
quel giorno
vota
la fiducia
a Mussolini
dirà
fu un voto
prudente
e patriottico
avevamo paura
della rivoluzione
con un'opposizione
che invece
si rivela
purtroppo
totalmente incapace
l'opposizione
in quel momento
non coglie
l'occasione
l'opposizione
è unita
anche se sono
molto diversi
fra loro
socialisti
democristiani
comunisti
però
però si riuniscono
e in queste riunioni
a leggere
i verbali
di queste riunioni
dell'opposizione
in quei giorni
di giugno
del 24
c'è da restare
sbigottiti
vedendo i nomi
il livello
dei nomi
che c'erano
il 13 giugno
alla prima
grande riunione
delle opposizioni
a Montecitorio
presiede
Bruno Buozzi
sindacalista
famoso
anche lui
sarà poi assassinato
lui dai nazisti
nel 44
Bruno Buozzi
alla vigilia
della liberazione
di Roma
tra i presenti
c'è Amendola
che appunto
due anni dopo
morirà anche lui
bastonato dai fascisti
c'è Gramsci
che morirà
dopo anni
di carcere
c'è Lussu
che abbiamo già raccontato
c'è Gronchi
che invece
se la caverà benissimo
e sarà Presidente
della Repubblica
nel dopoguerra
ebbene
questa riunione
di grandi personaggi
di grandi intelligenze
prende una decisione
catastrofica
in questa situazione
drammatica
in cui il governo
traballa
noi per ricattare
il governo
ci asteniamo
dai lavori
della Camera
ci ritiriamo
ce ne andiamo
si chiamerà
la secessione
dell'Aventino
come i plebei
nella storia di Roma
al tempo
di Menenio
Agrippa
l'Aventino
è il nome
con cui è passata
la storia
questa decisione
delle opposizioni
nei giorni roventi
del delitto
Matteotti
anziché stare in aula
a interrogare
tutti i giorni
il governo
noi
ce ne andiamo
non partecipiamo
ai lavori
illudendosi
che in quel modo
il governo
non avrebbe potuto
andare avanti
invece il governo
alla Camera
ha la maggioranza
assoluta
se ne frega
del fatto
che le opposizioni
non sono presenti
in aula
e va avanti
lo stesso
anzi proprio
in quei giorni
comincia a varare
nuovi regolamenti
che restringono
la libertà
di stampa
e il 7 agosto
al Consiglio Nazionale
del Partito Nazionale
Fascista
Mussolini
dirà
il regime
non si processa
che è come dire
qualunque cosa
possa venire fuori
noi
non ci assumiamo
nessuna responsabilità
e non ci saranno
conseguenze politiche
oh ragazzi
io sto facendo lunga
ma
tagliamo corto
è agosto
sarà un caso
ma sotto
ferragosto
camera chiusa
la borghesia
in vacanza
tutti al mare
ritrovano
il cadavere
di Matteotti
un cantoniere
consegna ai carabinieri
una giacca
che ha trovato
in un bosco
sporca di sangue
e la giacca
di Matteotti
vanno a scavare
nella zona
il giorno dopo
ferragosto
lo trovano
in questo bosco
della Quartarella
a qualche decina
di chilometri
da Roma
ormai è decomposto
devono convocare
il dentista
di Matteotti
per provare
per verificare
che è proprio lui
e intanto
gli inquirenti
indagano
perché c'è ancora
una magistratura
che in realtà
non è interamente
assoggettata
dal governo
la magistratura
va avanti
e fa il suo lavoro
, interroga
quelli che sono
in galera
interroga
quelli che sono
rimasti fuori
ma che hanno
le mani in pasta
come il generale
De Bono
ex capo
della polizia
De Bono
interrogato
dagli inquirenti
parla a ruota libera
dice certo
Dumini
ha avuto gli ordini
da Mussolini
direttamente
il testo
della deposizione
di De Bono
finisce sui giornali
di opposizione
lo legge anche
Dumini
in carcere
commento
di Dumini
De Bono
è una vecchia
prostituta
lui invece
Dumini
nega tutto
è un eroe
Dumini
lui nega tutto
però
manda segnali
scrive a Finzi
ex
sottosegretario
agli interni
mi accorgo
di essere
abbandonato
da tutti
gli avevano detto
che lo mettevano fuori
invece lo stanno
processando
dunque mi difenderò
il tono
straordinario
è di queste lettere
di Dumini
che dice
tutto senza dire
niente
dunque mi difenderò
e accuserò
se sarà
il caso
facendo uso
di documenti
cioè i documenti
attenti
ed è la mia
memoria
che è
buona
poi scrive
al suo avvocato
sapendo benissimo
che l'avvocato
riferirà
guardi che va
a finir male
faccio pubblicare
tutte le carte
e allora
saranno contenti
e ancora
dice al suo avvocato
guarda che a me
mi hanno garantito
l'immunità
e se non me la danno
parlo
dopodiché
Dumini però
ricattando
se la cava bene
alla fine
arrivano a un accordo
tu confessa
che hai fatto
tutto di tua iniziativa
e andrà a finire
benissimo
Dumini ci sta
dichiara
che l'iniziativa
è sua
e andrà a processo
con questa accusa
il 29 aprile
del 25
passano molti mesi
l'inchiesta
va avanti
il processo
sarà poi
alla fine
del 25
ma
il grande
respiro
di sollievo
ai vertici
del paese
e del regime
è quando
Dumini
confessa
tra virgolette
ho fatto
tutto
la mia iniziativa
bravo Dumini
grande Dumini
il federale di Roma
Italo Foschi
gli scrive
ho parlato di te
molto in alto
e ti assicuro
che il tuo contegno
è apprezzato
moltissimo
caro Dumini
sei un vero
eroe
degno
di tutta
la nostra
ammirazione
così
il federale di Roma
Italo Foschi
a cui
detto fra parentesi
lo stato italiano
un paio di mesi fa
ha dedicato
un francobollo
a 140 anni
dalla nascita
perché fra le altre cose
è quello che ha fondato
la squadra di calcio
della Roma
le persone
hanno meriti
e demeriti
insomma
però fatto sta
che questo francobollo
dedicato a uno
che diceva
a Dumini
sei un vero eroe
stride un pochino
ma chiusa parentesi
però il punto
è che è finita
perché politicamente
Mussolini
ha deciso
che a questo punto
è abbastanza
forte
da non aver paura
di niente
e il 3 gennaio
del 25
Mussolini
va alla Camera
dove fa il famoso
discorso
ai deputati fascisti
perché l'opposizione
è sempre sull'Aventino
e non partecipa
ai lavori
e ha una Camera
occupata solo
da deputati fascisti
e del listone
Mussolini
fa il famoso discorso
in cui dice
assumo io
io solo
la responsabilità
politica
morale
storica
di tutto quanto
è avvenuto
non sta parlando
specificamente
solo del delitto Matteotti
ma in generale
quello che è successo
in questi ultimi anni
è tutta responsabilità mia
se il fascismo
è stato
un'associazione
a delinquere
io sono il capo
di questa associazione
a delinquere
così
Mussolini
alla Camera
e il 25
che comincia
con questo discorso
è l'anno
delle leggi
fascistissime
che trasformano
lo Stato liberale
in una dittatura
ed è anche
l'anno del processo
a Dumini
e agli altri quattro
perché
Cesare Rossi
Marinelli
Filippelli
sì
erano indagati
come mandanti
favoreggiatori
ma nel luglio
del 25
il regime
ha fatto una piccola
amnistia
per i reati politici
e quindi
tutti fuori
processano
soltanto
adesso non la faccio lunga
sarebbe divertente
anche questa storia qua
del processo
che fanno
a Chieti
perché a Roma
il clima non è buono
no no
lo fanno a Chieti
che in quell'epoca
non si può raggiungere
praticamente
diciamo così
il difensore
di Dumini
e degli altri
è niente meno
che Roberto Farinacci
famoso avvocato
e segretario nazionale
del partito fascista
il quale
come avvocato
difende
Dumini
e gli altri
al tribunale di Chieti
dall'accusa di omicidio
Farinacci
arriva a Chieti
accolto
dalla banda municipale
che suona
giovinezza
e
dichiara
ai giornali
che il processo
non è contro
quei poverini
Dumini
e gli altri
è contro
le opposizioni
contro
quel Matteotti
che era un pericoloso
sovversivo
e contro
tutti quelli
che in nome
di Matteotti
vorrebbero
rovesciare il governo
e così via
Farinacci
trasforma il processo
in una grande
sceneggiata
alla fine
Dumini
e Volpi
sono condannati
per omicidio
preterintenzionale
non volevano
ammazzarlo
gli è morto
fra le mani
sono condannati
a cinque anni
e undici mesi
solo in tre
sono condannati
gli altri due
erano seduti davanti
nella macchina
e non hanno visto niente
quindi
loro tre
sono condannati
a cinque anni
e undici mesi
certo
ma ricordate
l'amnistia
che era stata
appena fatta
per gli omicidi
non valeva
ma se erano
omicidi
la sfondo politico
prevedeva
un certo sconto
comunque
quattro anni
di sconto
cinque anni
di condanna
quattro anni
di sconto
uno l'hanno già
fatto in galera
durante l'inchiesta
vengono messi fuori
subito
però per la serie
della gratitudine
Mussolini
non è per niente
grato
a Farinacci
per aver fatto
assoldere
Dumini
perché Mussolini
a Farinacci
aveva detto
nessun clamore
fate le cose
senza rumore
che non se ne parli
Farinacci
ha fatto le cose
in grande
risultato
Farinacci risponde
quando Mussolini
lo sgrida
Farinacci
gli risponde
che lui sta facendo
quello che bisogna fare
perché
cito
Matteotti
fu da vivo
un gran porco
Mussolini
una settimana
dopo la fine
del processo
costringe
Farinacci
a dimettersi
da segretario
del partito fascista
Farinacci
andrà nell'ombra
per un po'
poi come sapete
tornerà in auge
negli anni 30
sarà uno dei protagonisti
dell'antisemitismo
fascista
e poi
della Repubblica
di Salò
e sarà fucilato
dai partigiani
il 29 aprile
del 45
ma dato che parliamo
di gente fucilata
chiudiamo
andando a vedere
cosa è successo
a tutta questa gente
di cui abbiamo parlato
e di nuovo
la gratitudine
centra
come vedrete
De Bono
non è stato processato
inchiesta
interrogato
a lungo
alla fine
messo
senza
non messo
sotto accusa
fa una grande carriera
è senatore del regno
sarà governatore
della Libia
ministro delle colonie
comandante
durante la guerra
d'Etiopia
maresciallo
d'Italia
membro
del gran consiglio
del fascismo
come membro
del gran consiglio
del fascismo
il vecchissimo
ormai generale
De Bono
il 25 luglio
del 43
quella notte
a Fosa
si trova
a dover decidere
se votare o no
l'ordine del giorno
grandi
benché
fedelissimo
a Mussolini
non capisce tanto
la situazione
si lascia convincere
vota
l'ordine del giorno
grandi
che costringe
Mussolini
a dimettersi
ovviamente
Mussolini
se la lega il dito
De Bono
sarà arrestato
dalla Repubblica
di Salò
processato
condannato a morte
e fucilato
a Verona
l'11 gennaio
del 44
per ordine
di Mussolini
Marinelli
il segretario
amministrativo
del partito
quello che metteva
i soldi
per Dumini
e la cecca fascista
al contrario
degli altri
interrogato
dagli inquirenti
non parla
non fa nomi
non dice niente
il duce
gli è molto grato
ridiventa
segretario
amministrativo
del partito
deputato
sottosegretario
anche Marinelli
per sua sfortuna
facendo carriera
diventa membro
del gran consiglio
anche Marinelli
il 25 luglio
vota a favore
dell'ordine
del giorno
grandi
perciò
Mussolini
lo fa arrestare
condannare a morte
e fucilare
a Verona
insieme agli altri
ma il destino
più straordinario
è quello
di Aldo Finzi
Aldo Finzi
ha chiuso
con la politica
non ci crede più
e non lo vogliono più
è molto ricco
straricco
di famiglia
diventa un grande
industriale del tabacco
rimane fuori
dalla politica
però vive pur sempre
in Italia
nel 38
escono le leggi
razziali
Finzi è cattolico
ha sposato
la nipote
di un cardinale
ma è di
famiglia ebraica
non nasconde
la sua opposizione
alle leggi
razziali
viene invisto
con sospetto
dal regime
nel 41
finisce al confino
viene espulso
dal partito fascista
Aldo Finzi
entra in contatto
con esponenti
dell'antifascismo
nel novembre
del 43
a Roma
aderisce
alla resistenza
nel febbraio
viene arrestato
incarcerato
a Regina Celi
e poche settimane
dopo
quando i tedeschi
prelevano
a Regina Celi
335 persone
da fucilare
alle fosse ardeatine
come rappresaglia
per l'attentato
di Via Rasella
Aldo Finzi
è uno di quelli
che vengono portati
alle fosse ardeatine
il sottosegretario
fascista
del 24
con le mani
in pasta
nell'assassinio
di Matteotti
è uno dei martiri
delle fosse ardeatine
ora ditemi
in quale altro paese
possono succedere
delle cose del genere
gli altri
un po' meno
chiudiamo davvero
è un po' meno
drammatico
ma sono sempre
delle belle storie
italiane
Cesare Rossi
assolto da tutte
le accuse
però ha perso
il posto
e ha paura
e migra in Francia
gli tolgono
la cittadinanza
italiana
i fascisti
mandano dei gruppi
a pestarlo
quando ci riescono
subisce delle
aggressioni
poi viene attirato
con un tranello
in Italia
Cesare Rossi
arrestato
dalla polizia
fascista
condannato
a 30 anni
di carcere
dal tribunale
speciale
ne fa 11
poi esce
va al confino
esce di nuovo
sarà di nuovo
arrestato
e processato
nel dopoguerra
per il delitto
Matteotti
ma assolto
ma notate il dettaglio
è stato attirato
con un tranello
in Italia
Filippo Filippelli
ex direttore
del Corriere Italiano
espulso dal partito
sottoposto
a vigilanza
dalla polizia
radiato
dagli ordini
degli avvocati
a questo punto
non sapendo più
come campare
si rivolge
alla polizia
segreta
fascista
dicendo
io ho tante
conoscenze
fra gli antifascisti
vi posso aiutare
ci aiuti
a catturare
Cesarino Rossi
certo che vi aiuto
è lui
che organizza
il tranello
con cui
Cesare Rossi
viene fatto
tornare
in Italia
grazie a questo
Filippelli
riceve di nuovo
la tessera
del partito
è un milione
di lire
poi però
viene di nuovo
arrestato
per furto
otto anni
di prigione
ma lo liberano
per indulto
nel 34
è l'Italia fascista
ma è sempre
l'Italia
naturalmente
svuota carceri
lo mettono fuori
diventa
amministratore
di un'azienda
nel 38
fa bancarotta
fraudolenta
scappa all'estero
in Belgio
a Bruxelles
contatta
la polizia
segreta fascista
dicendo
io ho tante
conoscenze
fra gli antifascisti
se volete
vi aiuto
gli dicono
no grazie
anche lui
nel 47
di nuovo
arrestato
processato
per il diritto
Matteotti
amnistiato
stavolta
ultimo
Dumini
qui la gratitudine
c'è come
perché Dumini
l'hanno messo fuori
avete visto
l'hanno condannato
per carità
omicidio preterintenzionale
però tra una cosa e l'altra
è subito fuori
dopodiché
contatta Marinelli
e dice
adesso però
voglio i soldi
e i soldi
arrivano
gli danno
una montagna
di contanti
un mensile
di 5.000 lire
è l'epoca in cui
gli italiani
cantavano
se avessi
1.000 lire
al mese
ecco
a lui gli danno
5.000 lire
al mese
ma non gli basta
lui è americano
sa come funziona
il mondo moderno
prende contatti
con un editore
americano
proponendo
la pubblicazione
delle sue memorie
e comincia
a dire in giro
che lui
ha preso
5 anni
ma Mussolini
ne meritava
ora
sa come funziona
il mondo
ma si è dimenticato
come funziona
l'Italia
lo arrestano
per porto
abusivo
d'armi
lo condannano
a un anno
e due mesi
ma viene
graziato
dal re
Dumini
è scomodo
molto scomodo
bisogna
tenerselo
buono
si trasferisce
nelle colonie
in Somalia
lì lo arrestano
di nuovo
5 anni
di confino
dal confino
scrive
Dumini
a Emilio
De Bono
che è rimasto
un grande gerarca
dicendogli
anche qui
abbiate pazienza
io ho scritto
un memoriale
ma siccome lui
è americano
ha consegnato
il memoriale
a uno studio
legale
del Texas
più al sicuro
di così
non potrebbe essere
e lui dice
a De Bono
guarda che lì
ci sono i documenti
compromettenti
dice per Mussolini
no per te
De Bono
lo liberano
subito dalla prigione
si trasferisce
in Libia
riceve contratti
appalti
finanziamenti
Italo Balbo
governatore
della Libia
è costretto
a scrivere
a Mussolini
dicendo
toglimi
dalle scatole
Dumini
perché non ne posso più
si vuole arricchire
a tutti i costi
disturbo
sta facendo
un sacco di soldi
poi arriva la guerra
e le nostre colonie
vengono invase
dagli inglesi
Dumini
che è americano
e parla perfettamente
inglese
decide di restare
con gli inglesi
mi capirò benissimo
gli inglesi
lo prendono per una spia
lo arrestano
e lo condannano a morte
viene fucilato
e colpito
dice la leggenda
ma qualcuno dice
che è proprio documentato
da 17 pallottole
non muore
sopravvive
riesce a scappare
di nascosto
a raggiungere
le truppe di Rommel
che lo accoglie
come un eroe
lo fa rimpatriare
viene rimpatriato
in Italia
come un eroe
del fascismo
nel 47
inevitabilmente
viene processato
anche lui
di nuovo
stavolta
lo condannano
all'ergastolo
uno dice
eh
però c'è l'amnistia
togliati
l'ergastolo
diventano 30 anni
si fa effettivamente
sei anni
di prigione
nel 53
c'è l'amnistia
pella
condono totale
viene messo fuori
anno dopo
la Cassazione
annulla il condono
lo arrestano
di nuovo
finisce di nuovo
in galera
nel 56
viene graziato
Amerigo Dumini
morirà
nel 67
a 73 anni
perché è caduto
in casa
mentre giocava
con il suo cane
quanto a Matteotti
il 19 agosto
del 24
dopo il ritrovamento
del cadavere
è partito da Roma
il treno speciale
che trasportava
la bara
a Fratta Polesine
per i funerali
il treno parte
alle 6 di sera
e viaggia tutta la notte
per disposizione
del governo
per evitare
che la gente
si affolli
alle stazioni
arriva comunque
a Fratta Polesine
dove partecipano
migliaia di persone
ai funerali
poi per 20 anni
di lui
non si parla più
naturalmente
si ricomincia
a parlarne
durante la resistenza
quando le formazioni
partigiane
organizzate
dal partito socialista
si chiamano appunto
Brigate Matteotti
poi nel dopoguerra
in tutte le città italiane
piazze
vie
vengono dedicate
a Matteotti
ogni tanto se ne parla
ogni tanto meno
quest'anno se ne è parlato
tanto
tanto da dare l'impressione
che l'Italia
sia ancora capace
di gratitudine
verso chi si è fatto
ammazzare
in quel modo
per difendere
la libertà del paese
io spero che sia vero
che l'Italia
ne è ancora capace
grazie
grazie a tutti
buona serata